hey katie thanks for jumping on the call
no worries martin i heard you needed
help setting up your new website
yeah i have this repo here my travels
and all the code is here on github
but i want somewhere to run this code
and i also wanted to set up so that when
i push a new version here to github
the new version gets deployed
automatically to the cloud
well that's easy i can we can set that
all up for you in cloud run i can show
you right now in your browser
so i see you've got your code there all
on github
and you're logged into cloud console
right
uh on a google cloud platform uh let's
take a look
yep and i even created as an empty
project here
my travels i haven't done anything with
it except create it
okay great so if you want to go over
into the cloud run section
and create a new service we can get
started all right
very good let's see
cloud run is down here actually i'll pin
it as well so it's easy to get to
all right so here we are in the cloud
run section uh there's nothing here yet
yep so if you just want to go and click
create service
create service okay it looks up here
very nice
enabling the cloud run api all right
and what do i do here so under service
name
you said this was your travel website so
if you want to name it
my travels oh okay very good cloudron
api has been enabled very good my
travels okay yep
next oh container i don't think i have a
container image
well that's okay you don't have to have
one already what we can do is if you see
just below that deployed container it
has an option there saying
continuous to deploy from source control
ah
yes that's what i want all right
so so now you're gonna wanna yep so go
and set up with cloud build all right
very good
uh and i guess i need to enable
some apis here
oh this is looking good it says github
this is what i want
but no repositories available katie
well see that other big blue button
install
google cloud build you're going to need
to install cloud build as part of github
so if you want to click that click the
big blue
friendly button yeah
all right and here so now it took me to
to github and here i want to
do it specifically for my travels
very good read and write i guess
yep
all right let's see if oh look at that
that's my github repo
very nice uh
i understand that members blah blah blah
yes
sounds good and next or advanced options
here uh just click next
next okay good
very good okay build configuration
docker file
huh what's all this about okay so for
the branch
you're using a main branch so you're
going to want to make sure that you
yep in that selection there it's worked
out what your main branch is
oh it figured that out excellent yeah so
what this part will do is anytime you
push to your main branch
your service will be redeployed
oh that's exactly what i want uh let's
see i don't have a docker file
that's okay you don't need a docker file
what we can do is we can use cloud build
packs instead oh what are build packs
they're a standard way of being able to
build your container images you might be
familiar with them if you've used
something like heroku before
your code base doesn't need to change
but you will have to add
one file okay got it
so uh root is the build directory
yep but before we before we continue
with this martin
if you want to go back to your code base
we're going to need to add that one
file oh okay got it so here's my code
um i have my readme file here
no docker file or whatever the other
file are not here that you mentioned
that's okay so i see in your readme
you've got exactly the command that you
need to run
uh to run your application yeah right
and you run this after you you run this
after you install your dependencies
right
that's right okay so
what we're going to need to do is create
a special file
that will tell build packs to run that
python 3 flask run command
okay so create a new file called
procfile with a capital p
uh all right so let's see here
uh proc file
yup does it have a file extension
nope just proc file yes profile okay
here we are in the profile and if you
want to copy that command
from your readme into this proc file
yeah
and then at the start of that line type
in web
colon space like so
yep so what this will do is when the
build pack runs it will try to find a
proc file
and then it will execute the command
that you've tagged as
web web in this case stands for the web
service
and this is the commander will run when
you want to start your
web service we will need to add one
other thing to this command
and that's just um a host and a port
these are specific things that
cloud run needs to run as part of
what cloud run needs it says that i will
run anything that you put in a container
that's serving on host zero zero zero
zero
and listening on a port so after run if
you want to type
double dash host uh
host yup got it yep equals
0.0.0.0 oh okay very good
yep and then a space double dash
port equals dollar sign
capital port so that's an environment
variable
yeah so we could add these
configurations within
your flask app.pi itself
or we can get the proc file to run flask
with these configurations for us
seems to make sense to break it out into
its own file okay i like this
uh was that it for the project so what
you need to do
is save this file and commit it to your
repository and then push it up to github
oh okay got it so
add proc file is what i'll call it
submit that make sure i push that
up
it's thinking about it okay let's see
here
uh he jumped over refresh
yeah let's see if it made it up oh look
at that profile
it made it awesome so that's the only
change you need to make to your code
so if you want to jump back over into
cloud console we can continue with the
setup process
oh that's right we didn't go through
with the whole thing yeah what should i
do here
uh all these defaults are fine so if you
want to click save
okay let's see let's save down there
uh-huh cloud trigger will be created
once you create the service
okay yep so if you scroll down to smooch
yeah and click next okay next
and then this is your public website
right
yeah that's right i want everybody to
know about where i've traveled
yep so you're going to want to select
allow unauthenticated invocations
so that just means that everyone can see
your website ah
okay and then click create all right
and then we can sit back and watch this
all happen oh
okay creating dot dot dot
oh uh so setting i am policy
okay and then some other stuff going on
here
so what's going on right now okay so
because we didn't have a container to
start off with what cloud run needs to
do is deploy a service with a
placeholder container
this container if you end up seeing it
means that
it's a placeholder but also it means
that you have somewhere that your
service can sit if something goes wrong
and
the placeholder will say have some
debugging steps if you need some help
but what it's doing now is after it's
created this build
cloud trigger which will fire this
process any time your code changes
what it's doing is it's building and
deploying from
repository so build packs understand
specific language setups
like python and java and go and some
others
what it'll do is it's worked out because
you have a
python setup it will use a python
environment it will install your
dependencies
that you have in your requirements.txt
and then as the entry point on your
container it will run
that command that you specified in the
proc file
this bill pack will build the container
for you
and then it will that will be the
container that
cloud run deploys so all you had to do
was add that one command
to get this all started so cloudrun will
deploy anything that has a container but
you don't
have to use docker to build that
container you can use something like
build packs
i see and build packs yeah build packs
maybe make it a little easier you don't
have to know docker to do this
you don't have to you just need to tell
it you need to use
a standard language that it understands
implicitly
so it understands for java how to
install
java dependencies for python how to
install python dependencies
but it doesn't know how to run your
service because there are so many
different ways that you could start
a web server so that's why you need to
tell it explicitly
when you want to start my web server
here is the command that you want to run
and in your case it was run flask
all right that was ah yes
this yeah piece that i ran otherwise got
it
yeah all right uh
let's see it's pending
there we go oh so uh let's see
uh so it contin it uh is done building
my code now yep so if you want to click
on that url there that starts with my
travels
you'll have your website nice let's have
a look
huh look at that it is my travel website
this is amazing so
i really like this now what if i want to
make updates to either the content
or if i want to make updates to the code
here what do i do
well now that we've set up that cloud
build trigger all you need to do to
redeploy your website is
update the code in your main branch on
your
remote repository so last time we did
this
you were in vs code if you want to jump
over into github now
we can make a small change and redeploy
your website
oh cool okay so we'll i could like you
said i could do this in vs code but
but let's let's do it over here so yeah
i i kind of i like
how oops i like how it says my travels
there
but but it's not quite i don't know
not quite personal enough but i want to
make it a little more personal
so what if i go into the home template
here
and i edit it not from vs code but from
github directly
you can do it in either place i guess
and i will say martin's travels and then
okay
and here it will loop over very good
let's scroll down here i'll commit that
change
you see that little yellow dot that's
appeared oh yeah that's new what's that
that is the status symbol that your
cloud build trigger is currently
processing
ah so if you click that
you can see more details oh right
details
okay
and then if you click on view more
details it will take you back into
the google cloud console and will show
your running build log
so here i'm seeing the the build log as
it's running
okay new stuff is popping up in this
window
looking good so far no error messages as
far as i can see
no and you can see the steps there the
first step is build pack which builds
the
container the second one is push which
pushes the container
and then the third one is deploy that
will use that container and then
redeploy your service and this is going
to happen anytime
you update the main branch on your repo
so
you can edit in vs code and push it up
you can edit it in the command line and
push it up you can edit it directly in
github
anywhere that will be a commit on that
main branch
of the remote repository so you have to
remember to push your code for it to
trigger
but anytime you edit that code this
trigger will redeploy everything
and now i made an edit to a template
here
if i made edit made and add a bit to
python code would it rebuild
the python code it'll rebuild everything
from your source repository
oh it's done yeah so if you refresh your
website
your change should be there all right
let's have a look
martin's travels great success
thank you for showing me katie this was
really easy
no worries i hope you get to add more
things to your travels soon but
you can now update your website
automatically with
cloud build and cloud run excellent
thank you for watching if you have
suggestions on what we should bring up
in future episodes
or if you have questions about what we
did here in this episode
please add them in the comments below
bye
you